oh hi there i'm gev welcome to the sloma
guys today we'll be using slow motion
to learn how a film camera works a film
camera for movies not for stills
this is a 16 millimeter film camera it's
russian it's called a krasnogorsk
3 which i definitely just read and
didn't have to google how to pronounce
it
we'll be loading up with some 16
millimeter film and using the phantom
to show all its magic imagery is usually
captured onto film through a lens with a
photosensitive chemical reaction you can
see that the light
hitting this film has darkened it it's a
color negative film so
areas of very bright light will burn in
a dark image and that'll then be flipped
in the development process and you can
see here the area i left behind
is slowly darkening as light from the
room exposes
it and i can just speed that up here if
you were then to develop that you'd end
up with
something that looks like this first
thing i'm going to do is load this bad
boy with some films i'm going to turn
the frame rate down to very low
uh eight frames a second put a little
bit of tension in the old spring
it's a wind-up camera this pressure
plate comes out
this camera has single perf reels so
that's the type of film i'm going to put
in it it basically just means the
sprocket holds down only one side of the
film and you can fit
either sound or use a format called
super 16
and shoot a wider image if your camera
has a wider gate so that's the type of
film we've got here just a single perf
16 millimeter film even though the image
size is different between these two
formats
the width of the film itself is indeed
16 millimeters
okay this is now loaded the film's on
this one it's going to be taken up
by this one so it'll all end up here and
it's looped through
going through here this pressure plate
is keeping the film
flat against the the focal plane
and when running it looks something like
this
you would never want to usually load a
film camera in such a bright room
next thing to do is to pop this back on
a lot of people would also tape around
to prevent light leakage now that we're
loaded up with film we can set the frame
rate so we'll do
24 which is the standard recording frame
rate of film this camera will actually
go all the way up to
48 okay lens is off
i will now use a camera to film me using
a camera
to film a camera here's a selfie i took
on a camera of me using a camera to film
me using i've just realized i can
actually take more of this off to show
more there we go
as we learned with our slo-mo dslr video
a 45-degree mirror will let you look
through the lens the mirror will then
move out of the way revealing the
shutter doors which also move out of the
way
and the image will be exposed on the
sensor then the shutter closes
then the mirror comes back down with
this film camera it's a very similar
principle when you look through the
viewfinder you get the correct
perspective because you're looking
through the actual lens
this is done by bouncing the image off
these beam splitting mirrors and off
this
mirrored disc placed at 45 degrees very
similar to the stills camera
what you're seeing here isn't the film
plane it's actually a path
back to the viewfinder on the back this
system differs slightly from the dslr in
that this mirror doesn't move out of the
way
to reveal a shutter that then opens to
reveal
the film plane this mirror is the
shutter itself this is a rotary disk
shutter
and this is how it works
this camera is rolling at 24 frames a
second and the gap
in the shutter disc determines the
shutter speed for every half rotation of
this disc
which is one frame the film is exposed
for 1
60th of a second and that is determined
by the the size of the gap in the
shutter there
this is what you would see if you were
looking through the viewfinder at me
pouring water on the ground if you could
also see in slow motion this is what it
would look like
you can see here side by side that the
areas of darkness in the viewfinder are
actually the exposures on the film you
cannot see
through the viewfinder when light is
hitting the film itself
so you're basically seeing the opposite
cycles this is what it looks like from
the inside as film is being
dragged through the gate you may
remember that any movement in your
subject
while the shutter is open will cause
motion blur but a dslr
sensor is stationary if film is
constantly moving how do you avoid every
single frame being a complete blur
as the film is pulled through the camera
to show you how this clever part works
i'm going to write numbers
on each frame this is one second of film
at 24 frames a second
and we're going to run this through the
camera so we can see what's actually
happening with the film
all the slo-mo in this video is being
captured at a thousand frames a second
in 4k which is approximately 40 times
slower
here we go one second through the camera
this is some absolutely amazing
engineering here every single exposure
on every frame of film
the film is perfectly stationary and by
the time the shutter comes around for a
new exposure
the film has moved without us even
seeing to the next frame
in order to see how this works i'm going
to take the disc off
entirely so you can now see the film at
all times
without the shutter you can see when the
film moves
the whole mechanism is timed so
perfectly that
as the shutter covers the film the film
is moved down which prevents
any streaking or motion blur from the
film itself if i
superimpose the shutter back on you can
see it
only moves when it's under the mirror
this is so fascinating to me and because
the shutter and the film pull down speed
are linked
no matter what frame rate you shoot this
will always be the case
so now i want to see the mechanism that
is pulling the film down
every time and in order to get a better
view of that
i'm going to take off this piece which
should reveal the
pull down claw this lens makes
everything look ginormous
so you can see as i press record here
this mechanism in the middle is leaning
forward at the top of its cycle and as
it leans forward
this claw goes perfectly into the
sprocket holes
of the film pulling it down into the
perfect position
for each exposure
i'm very impressed this camera still
works honestly it started production in
1971 so that's a lot of moving parts
that you're asking to last
half a century at this point just for
the heck of it now i'm going to write
frame numbers on again but this time for
a second's worth the film at
48 frames a second so everything in the
camera will be working at double the
speed now
if you projected this back at 24 frames
a second you would get
half speed slow motion or if you
projected it back at 48 frames a second
get some very hobbity looking footage
and there we have it a wonderful slow-mo
look at some old-school
analog tech i love it did you know
that there were film cameras made that
could shoot thousands
of frames a second maybe we should take
a look at one of those
one of these days if you found that
video interesting make sure you
subscribe i hope you did i enjoyed
making it
uh give it a like if you want and i'll
see you in the next video
thank you very much for watching